was wurde eigentlich aus dem
pflegenotstand dieses thema haben unsere
politiker ja neulich im
bundestagswahlkampf erstmals entdeckt
sie wissen ja pflegenotstand
überforderte schlecht bezahlte schläger
private pflege ketten die hauptsächlich
an den profit decken alles nicht schön
aber es gibt auch gute nachrichten
ich finde es besonders beeindruckendes
bei uns in bayern zu hause am meisten
gepflegt wird denn zu hause zu bleiben
und den eigenen vier wänden ist die
schönste form älter zu werden
dann bleibt du doch mal zu hause dazu
werden wenn sie kostet den staat wegen
bitten liegen sie bei sich zu hause denn
da ist es am schönsten ist kann er sagen
aber dann müsste man tatsächlich
deutlich mehr tun für menschen die ihre
angehörigen zu hause pflegen die
pflegereform von 2017 hat zwar dazu
geführt dass mehr pfleger endlich nach
tarif bezahlt werden aber dafür werden
die mehrausgaben wie sich jetzt
herausgestellt hat direkt weitergereicht
an die heimbewohner ja was dazu führt
dass bald noch mehr auf sozialhilfe
angewiesen sind es gibt so viel zu tun
in diesem land zum glück hat niko
semlitsch die lösung für alles endlich
die lösung aller probleme mit nico sim
slot
[Musik]
hallo ich mache mir oft sorgen um meine
zukunft werde ich von meinem job immer
leben können würde ich im zweifelsfall
arbeitslosengeld bekommen werde ich
weiter meine miete zahlen können werde
ich später mal rente willkommen und dann
fällt mir auf das sind ja alles
hochpolitische fragen und dann überlege
ich manchmal was könnte meine regierung
für leute wie mich ganz konkret tun und
da hatte die regierung von nrw letzte
woche ein super vorschlag ein
kopftuchverbot im kindergarten
ja und da dachte ich das würde mir auch
ganz konkret helfen also gerade im
alltag aber auch wenn es um meine
ernährung geht bin ich natürlich auf
kluge antworten aus der politik
angewiesen massentierhaltung
pflanzengifte bienensterben da sind
intelligente lösungen gefragt
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
hat er jetzt eine idee ich weiß gar
nicht ob sie das mitbekommen haben
ihr vorschlag war ein kopftuchverbot im
kindergarten und da dachte ich stimmt
das wird das bienensterben bestimmt
aufhalten
warum äußert sich die
landwirtschaftsministerin überhaupt zum
kopftuchverbot ich glaube weil das
mitten in ihren kompetenzbereich welt
nicht nur in sachen digitalisierung und
breitbandausbau sieht es düster aus auch
in anderen bereichen ist deutschland auf
dem weg in ein entwicklungsland überall
wo menschen beruflich anderen menschen
helfen werden sie vom staat im stich
gelassen ich sag nur altenheime
sie wissen schon oder diese großen
häuser häuser wo wir später alle mal
alleine vor dem fernseher auf den tod
warten
ist doch so aktuell fehlen 17.000
pfleger kein wunder ist ein beinharter
job schlecht bezahlt und man muss sich
ständig von dementen mit immer der
gleichen geschichten nerven lassen und
man muss sich ständig von dementen mit
immer der gleichen geschichte nur acht
jahre alten pfleger den job im schnitt
aus was wäre die antwort mehr lohn der
eine möglichkeit mehr leute einstellen
ruhepausen verlängern oder und das wäre
glaube ich die einfachste lösung im
kopftuch verbot im kindergarten
[Applaus]
nico hofmann und herren hat die lösung